i'm always depressed all the time it's
like a sledgehammer to the legs it's
really hard to get out of bed will you
have a suicidal yeah all the time
[Music]
i had a really rough time in high school
so like i still have like ptsd from that
[ __ ] she used to get teens in high
school or something oh all the time it
was so confusing uh cause like my dad
just died so like you'd think like
they'd be like fake nights but not
staten island
they don't give a [ __ ] down there i
always thought there was something wrong
with me my whole entire life i was like
i have no friends you know i've been to
like three different schools everybody
hates me so it has to be me and then i
left staten island and i was like it was
literally everybody else it's like fear
of abandonment like i'm gonna lose my
friends right lose my girlfriend like my
family hates me and i would always just
like
be all around and be worried all the
time and i'd be freaking out
depression affects more than like 16
million people in this country and
there's no like cure per se but for
anyone dealing with it there are
treatments that can help
first of all if you think you're
depressed you know see a doctor and talk
to them about medication and also be
healthy eating right and exercise can
make a huge difference
how often do you still battle with
depression oh i'm always depressed all
the time um i have to constantly bring
myself out of it like i wake up
depressed but like i'm like okay now i
know my steps because i you learn from
real like now i have to go outside and
be in the sun for a little bit or go for
a walk or like start the day this way
it's all just programming yourself to
trick your brain well you have a
suicidal yeah all the time but i can't
because i got a mom and a sister and
like a family so like i've always been
suicidal but i've never had like the
balls
which i'm very uh lucky is looking in
the mirror hard yeah i don't like how i
look i [ __ ] freak out uh i don't have
mirrors in my house no mirrors no it
just doesn't it doesn't work for me how
do you stop running from yourself
because you can't live in a world with
no mirrors right that's something i have
to work on i have to i'm definitely
working on trying to love myself more
and be less insecure and i'm doing a lot
of dbt therapy it's pretty much for
people that have like mental illness and
it teaches you steps and ways
uh to combat uh like depressive feelings
and [ __ ] like that and it's super
helpful so if you guys ever
need help you should check out dbt and
cbt which is cognitive cognitive
behavior i do cbt sometimes it's just
sitting there and just talking but like
it's you know it's always been helpful
to me
it's like steps to like thought
processing like you have these thoughts
you have these feelings you have these
urges you're gonna freak out try waiting
it out ten minutes right try going for a
walk how do you know when it's time to
go get help like okay i'm doing too much
when [ __ ] gets like just when it just
gets a little insurmountable or like
people are like hey my friends will tell
me now we're at a point where like
people will come over and be like hey
we're all like worried so you should go
i got i got a good group around me where
then they give a [ __ ]
i'm all for like
all the awareness and you know anything
i can do to help for sure there's a lot
of people that have it it's like a
sledgehammer to the legs it's really
hard to get out of bed so like if it
could help anybody i'm all for it always
you think you've ever hit rock bottom oh
yeah i hit it all the time my rock model
is when like
people are scared of my life and i have
to go away and then i have to bring
myself back up again so like i think
i've hit it a few times and uh you know
as long as you're around good supportive
people you should be able to you know
and then if you're strong enough you'll
be able to get out of it you've had a
hard time sharing all the parts of
yourself
in relationships
no i share too much and i scare the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of people uh because i
have like a lot of issues and stuff and
i i like to be very upfront about that
so there's no like surprises like i
don't want you to be surprised like if i
like uh you know have to go away to a
rehab or like if i have to go to like
certain therapy or something like that
because you know it just like breaks the
ice easier and like i don't want to
waste your [ __ ] time yeah you know
what i mean so like i think like i come
across
very like
intense and like i think that scares a
lot of people away
everybody has an opinion on pete
davidson and what's good
for pete davidson right what does pete
davidson think is good for him i think
right now staying on track
trying to you know not focus on
relationships or the media or anything
like that
i think just you know doing what i'm
doing just trying to keep your head down
keep working and hopefully people see
the work i think i think actions speak
louder than words i feel like i'm in a
good place right now what does that mean
i'm just really looking forward to like
doing cool stuff with a lot of my
friends have a lot of cool stuff coming
out and we're working on stuff so it's
just nice to be in a place where that's
the focus and not like
you know anything else